[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 so herminia Fernández
comenzamos
en el norte de chipre la educación se ha
convertido en el principal sector
económico por encima del turismo
generando un tercio del pib según
información oficial no menos de 23
universidades se concentran en este
estado autoproclamado y reconocido solo
por Turquía que lo ocupa desde 1974 unos
50.000 estudiantes principalmente de
África Oriente próximo y el
subcontinente indio vienen atraídos por
cursos asequibles con el sello de
aprobación europeo pero algunos de ellos
se desilusionan rápidamente por ser
Víctimas de promesas abusivas y ofertas
engañosas de parte de sus reclutadores
que han desembocado en situaciones
dramáticas este reportaje fue realizado
por corintham beneath y Erika olavarría
quien nos acompaña hoy en el estudio les
saludo Erika y le pregunto el tema de
este reportaje sobre el auge de las
universidades en chipre del Norte llegó
a través del programa de periodismo
ciudadano y lanzadores de alerta de
France 24 llamado los observadores Quién
hizo la denuncia a través de este medio
Sí herminia qué tal los observadores el
programa de periodismo ciudadano las
personas mandan videos los observadores
los ciudadanos comunes a France 24
denunciando situaciones en este caso
fueron dos camerunenses que denunciaron
que estaban siendo expulsados de chipre
del Norte y eso que habían pagado caras
universidades nos pusimos entonces a
investigar y descubrimos que había un
sistema que era muy bueno para muchas
personas como decías tú cincuenta mil
decenas de miles de personas de
distintas partes del mundo que vienen a
estudiar pero también hay una pequeña
parte que viene que siente engañada y se
da cuenta que es difícil vivir en chipre
que es caro para ellos y muchas veces se
quedan sin recursos en los estudios ni
siquiera pueden pagar una segunda
mensualidad o un segundo semestre no
tienen que comer no tienen donde dormir
y se encuentran en una situación muy
crítica que es lo que vamos a ver en el
siguiente reportaje Así es Erika a
continuación veremos el reportaje y
luego volveremos con usted
[Música]
estos dos estudiantes cameronenses
soñaban con estudiar en chipre del Norte
y alertaron a la redacción de los
observadores porque los expulsaron sin
motivo cuando cruzaban la aduana y nunca
les devolvieron el dinero sin embargo
habían pagado cientos de euros en las
inscripciones universitarias eso le
sirve de visa para este territorio
reconocido como estado solo por Turquía
que lo ocupó en 1974
Desde esa fecha La Isla está dividida
entre la autoproclamada República turca
de chipre del Norte y la República de
chipre miembro de la Unión Europea las
historias de estos estudiantes son
apenas una muestra del oficios de un
sistema universitario atractivo y a la
vez criticado
[Música]
estudiantes del mundo entero en este
anfiteatro en chipre del Norte esta
imagen es moneda común son 50.000 según
las autoridades vienen de África medio
oriente o de India y están inscritos en
algunas de las 23 universidades de esta
parte de la isla
la más importante la Instant
mediterránea en University es una
vitrina para chipre del Norte
nuestra universidad cuenta con 33
centros de investigación uno de estos
trabaja en vehículos eléctricos
el establecimiento cuenta con 15.000
estudiantes 4000 vienen de 110 países
diferentes atraídos principalmente por
su departamento de ingeniería civil
como estos estudiantes vienen de países
en vías de desarrollo buscan estudios
basados en las Ciencias y la tecnología
estamos en Europa y chipre del Norte
constituye una muy buena alternativa a
los estudios en países de Europa central
o del norte de Europa
los estudios en chipre del Norte tienen
un precio relativamente accesible entre
3000 y 5000 euros al año 15 de estas
universidades tienen diplomas
reconocidos por Turquía y por lo tanto
son aceptados en Europa un atractivo
extra Y eso aunque según numerosos
estudiantes la calidad de la enseñanza
en chipre del Norte deja mucho que
desear
[Música]
apoyadas por las autoridades las
universidades hacen de todo por atraer a
los estudiantes el sector es un Pilar
financiero para el norte
representa un tercio del pib más incluso
que el turismo
pero este sistema tiene un defecto los
agentes son normalmente antiguos
estudiantes pagados a comisión por las
universidades para atraer al máximo de
alumnos cueste lo que cueste
[Música]
la asociación voice recibe los
testimonios de estudiantes mal
orientados por sus agentes
la mayoría de las experiencias que
tienen las personas que vienen a través
de un agente es que les prometen que
encontrarán un trabajo es fácil alojarse
y que no es caro
el terreno favorito de los agentes son
las redes sociales allí multiplican las
promesas muchas veces engañosas o
ambiguas
algunos anuncios hablan de estudios en
chipre sin precisar que se trata de
chipre del Norte
otros mencionan Europa sin detallar que
el norte no forma parte de la Unión
Europea otros agentes prometen becas del
menos un 50% del precio de inscripción y
de repente todos pueden obtener una beca
del 50% pero es verdaderamente una beca
si todo el mundo tiene un 50% de
reducción personalmente creo que suena
muy bien en el papel suena como una
buena estrategia de marketing Y claro
hay otras cosas ridículas Como por
ejemplo decir es Europa ustedes pueden
moverse en cualquier país europeo
hablamos con agentes y lo que dicen es
hablamos directamente con los padres y
no con los estudiantes y los padres
tienen tendencia a creer aquello que
queremos hacerles creer pero el
principal problema son las universidades
porque son las que pagan a los agentes y
que se niegan a pedirle cuentas a los
agentes nosotros logramos contactar a un
agente está estudiando un doctorado y
asegura trabajar Honestamente Aunque
pide el anonimato
Yo trabajo con seis o siete
universidades
como en todo hay buenos y malos agentes
mienten para ganar dinero este tema nos
preocupa mucho porque como usted puede
ver me encanta la educación
muchos jóvenes afirman haber llegado sin
saber que la isla estaba dividida sin
embargo esta gente asegura que él habla
de chipre del Norte en sus anuncios
si quiere mi Facebook Mire mi Instagram
usted verá todo habla de chipre Norte
sin embargo muchas publicaciones de su
página solo mencionan chipre y no chipre
del Norte en 2021 proponía Incluso un
precio para atravesar hacia el sur la
parte Europea de La Isla algo ilegal y
su explicación es confusa
Qué quiere decir que usted ayuda a la
gente a cruzar hacia el sur no no no no
usted sabe en Camerún nosotros tenemos
es decir los agentes un lenguaje una
manera de hablar por la manera en que
hablamos tradicionalmente en la lengua
de viaje usted escucha decir que alguien
atravesó al extranjero alguien que usted
sabe Hay tantas maneras de hablar y
también porque nosotros tenemos
universidades al sur hacemos eso también
pero este agente se niega a decirnos con
cuántas universidades trabaja en el sur
muchos agentes también son acusados de
pasar personas del Norte al sur por unos
400 euros se puede cruzar la línea
divisoria en algunos sitios poco
vigilada es necesario solo cruzar unas
alambradas las autoridades de chipre
afirman que en 2022 más de 7000 personas
que llegaron con visa estudiante al
norte cruzaron esa línea El Paso
siguiente es la demanda de asilo
y luego son llevados a este campo de
refugiados allí las condiciones de vida
son difíciles como lo documentó uno de
nuestros observadores
pero las posibilidades de obtener el
estatuto de refugiado son mínimas
si los estudiantes terminan cruzando al
sur es porque fueron engañados por sus
agentes las condiciones de vida en el
norte se hacían muy difíciles de
soportar
Stanley Paul no son nigerianos
aprovechan su domingo para hacer compras
Pero no para ellos estos alimentos los
distribuyen entre estudiantes con
problemas económicos en nicosia del
Norte
estas dos chicas nigerianas nos han
pedido mantener el anonimato si no
podrían ser expulsadas
el alquiler es muy alto 400 libras
esterlinas por mes es duro comer en esta
Isla Yo no esperaba que todo fuera tan
duro Yo pensaba que sería color de rosa
Como algunos dicen
la ayuda que financiada con donaciones
está destinada sobre todo a estudiantes
africanos
Sierra Leona todos los países de África
en general entramos en contacto vía
WhatsApp sí a través de WhatsApp si a
través de nuestro grupo WhatsApp y les
proponemos distintas ayudas hoy es la
comida y otro día podría ser y hasta
zapatos incluso comida cocinada hacemos
lo máximo por ocuparnos de ellos sobre
todo de su salud mental
Cuando llegaste a la isla
Hace seis meses
pudimos Incluso financiar el regreso de
cuatro estudiantes a Nigeria y Camerún
muchos se deprimen no tienen donde
dormir no tienen nada que hacer en la
isla Entonces mejor que verlos crear
problemas aquí vienen a vernos nosotros
reunimos dinero y les pagamos el billete
para que regresen a casa
desorientados algunos alumnos caen en el
tráfico de drogas y algunas estudiantes
en la prostitución
Pero hay Quienes se aferran a sus sueños
como John que dejó los estudios y de
paso se quedó sin documentación legal se
puso a trabajar en la construcción pero
tuvo un grave accidente
repentinamente caídas de un edificio
caí de espaldas y me rompí los dientes
tuve una luxación en la mano izquierda y
en la pierna derecha también me llevaron
al hospital
pese a las heridas John recibió solo
antibióticos muchos extranjeros son
discriminados también en la salud
pública
de
repente vi a la policía me llevaron
herido a la cárcel y en el brazo no
hicieron nada tampoco ni una inyección
la prisión fue el infierno el infierno
cada mañana recorre la zona industrial
de nicosia para encontrar un trabajo y
regularizar su situación
no es fácil encontrar un trabajo Cada
día me responden lo mismo no hay trabajo
en este momento a veces se quedan con mi
número de teléfono
esta empresa parece de alimentos para
animales
[Música]
buscas un trabajo de tiempo completo sí
muchas personas como tú han venido antes
Entonces si entiendo bien por ahora no
tiene trabajo a tiempo completo
yo no es el primer alumno en situación
de precariedad en proponer sus servicios
hasta empresa Pero en chipre del Norte
los trabajos son escasos
Espero encontrar un trabajo con el que
pueda ganar entre 20 a 30 euros por día
así podré ahorrar dinero y volver a
estudiar Mi máster que cuesta cerca de
4.500 euros
mi sueño es ir a Canadá y tener una
calidad de vida que me permita ayudar a
mi familia y a todos a quienes lo
necesiten
A fines de 2022 el gobierno de Nigeria
fue el primero en advertir públicamente
de los excesos de los agentes el
ministro de educación de facto de chipre
del Norte nos aseguró por su parte que
va a crear un sistema de acreditación de
los agentes y de visa electrónica
promesas que no convencen a los críticos
del sistema los estudiantes que cruzamos
lo repiten para vivir la experiencia de
chipre del Norte hay que apoyarse
económicamente e informarse
personalmente a través de internet Para
no caer en la trampa de los agentes
[Música]
estamos de vuelta con Erika olavarría
una de las autoras de este reporteros
que acabamos de ver Erika vemos Que
sobre los agentes recae gran parte de la
responsabilidad de esta situación que
vive miles de estudiantes que se le
puede sugerir a quienes están planeando
seguir estudios en chipre del Norte
sí que son muchas personas lo que nos
decían muchos estudiantes que sí han
seguido en las universidades y que
consideran que es exitosa su estadía en
chipre del Norte primero es ver la
calidad de la universidad la que vimos
en el reportaje la Easter mediterránea
University es una de las mejores de
hecho se encuentra dentro de las mil
mejores del mundo según el ranking de
Shanghai esa no tiene problemas sin
embargo hay otras que son de dudosa
calidad por lo tanto un indicio es ver
si los diplomas de la universidad son
reconocidos por Turquía y también hay
que tener mucho cuidado pues los
estudiantes muchas veces son
discriminados en el acceso a la salud y
de hecho a los extranjeros en chipre del
Norte se les exige un examen decida de
VIH una vez al año y hay Mucho racismo
sobre todo con los estudiantes de África
Gracias Erika por acompañarnos el día de
hoy hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]